[Music]
there's a long list of actors who have
voiced many of our favorite Disney
characters and many of these talented
people weren't even old enough to drive
at the time these movies and cartoons
were released if you new to our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up because
today we'll be showing you 10 teenagers
behind popular Disney characters Tyler
Myrna as Prince James teenage actor
Tyler Myrna was the voice behind Prince
James in the Disney Junior series Sofia
the first on seasons two and three of
the show Tyler's voice can be heard as
the easygoing character who's always
willing to lend his sister Sophia a
helping hand he was 13 when he
auditioned for the role and it took six
months for him to finally hear back from
the show's producers Tyler says he was
so excited to work on the program
because his little sister is such a huge
fan of the show Jonathan Taylor Thomas
as Simba actor Jonathan Taylor Thomas
his acting career took off when he
appeared on the 96 comm home improvement
during his time on the show he was cast
as the speaking voice of the young Simba
in the film The Lion King Jonathan's
appearance and personality later served
as the creative inspiration behind the
design and animation of the character
when you look at young Simba's
appearance you can definitely see the
resemblance between the young tub and
the actor adriana caselotti as Snow
White at the age of 18 adriana caselotti
overheard her dad talking on the phone
to Disney executives about an upcoming
film Adriana who had been trained by her
dad to be an opera singer started
singing in the background loud enough
for Disney executives to immediately
fall in love with her voice she was cast
as a lead role in the 1937 film Snow
White and Disney fans have been in love
with her angelic voice ever since she
was only paid 970 dollars for working on
the film and she was prohibited by
Disney from appearing in any other
movies or productions to protect the
illusion of Snow White Bobby Driscoll as
Peter Pan as a young child actor Bobby
Driscoll became one of Disney's most
popular stars by the time he was 14 he
had many acting gigs under his belt
including his role as the voice of Peter
Pan Bobby's body was also used as a
reference for the animated characters
physical appearance and body movements
spencer lacy genesis elsa when frozen
was released fifteen-year-old spencer
lisa gannis was the voice behind teenage
elsa she had just a few speaking lines
in the film and was paid 926 dollars and
20 cents for the gig she made headlines
when her paycheck was exposed and fans
of the movie demanded to be compensated
more especially since the movie made
over 1 billion dollars it was later
revealed Spencer actually received over
$10,000 in residual payments and Disney
loved her voice so much that they have
hired her to perform more voice work in
the future Miley Cyrus as penny when
Miley Cyrus was 16 years old she was
hired as the voice of penny in bolts the
singer and actress says she was always
teased for her deep and husky voice but
it was her unique voice that grabbed
Disney execs attention
Miley now loves that her voice is
different and she's so glad penny
doesn't have the stereotypical girly
voice as usually heard in most animated
films
Eileen woods as Cinderella in 1948
Eileen woods as friends asked her to
record a few songs including a dream is
a wish your heart made they presented
the songs to Walt Disney and he fell in
love with Eileen boys two days later he
hired the 19 year old as the lead role
in the animated film Cinderella
Eileen beat out more than 300 other
voice actresses who had auditioned for
the role Katharine Beaumont as Alice
Catherine Beaumont had been working as a
Disney voice actress for a few years
when she was cast as the voice of Alice
in the 1951 film Alice in Wonderland
catherine was just 13 years old at the
time and Walt Disney had selected her
for the role because of her charming
British accent she later went on to
voice a part of Wendy in the 1953
animated film Peter Pan Ariel winter is
Sofia since 2012
Ariel winter has been the voice behind
Sofia in the Disney Junior series Sofia
the first as the voice of the magical
young girl who lives in a fairy tale
world
Ariel says she loves playing the
character because she believes Sofia is
a great role model for young girls she
hopes to continue her role as a magical
princess so she can keep educating girls
on what it's like to be a strong woman
al de carvalho as mallanna
at the age of fourteen alia vaalu landed
the role as mallanna without even odd
auditioning for the part the teen was
discovered by casting agents after she
won a local singing competition in Oahu
she was then hired for the role and
she's now the youngest person to voice
of Disney Princess
she says voicing the character was
actually pretty easy because she's
naturally a very animated person with a
voice that's full of intense emotions
were you surprised by any of these teens
who voice your favorite Disney
characters react in the comment section
down below and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up
[Music]